we just saw this is joint work with my
mentor at twitter luca belly and my phd
advisor maurice hart
so the paper is called from optimizing
engagement to measuring value so i'm
going to go over the first
part of this first which is the
optimizing for engagement part so this
is the part that platforms do currently
you know we're all familiar with these
kinds of platforms that rank content you
see using machine learning algorithms
one of the most basic ways to
come up with some objective for ranking
content is by using a behavioral signal
so in its simplest form we could say
that we're going to optimize for clicks
so what this means is that for
every piece of content you see the
recommender system logs whether or not
you clicked on it and we're going to
create a model that predicts from those
features of the items whether you're
going to click on the item or not
in practice these platforms have many
different kinds of signals so the
objective is actually a little bit more
complicated it's usually some sort of
weighted combination of various kinds of
signals clicking favorites replying etc
of course
optimizing for engagement also leads to
many perverse outcomes so i've already
shown some of you this graph this is a
chart that mark zuckerberg posted on his
facebook
um so it comes from research that
they've done at facebook they found that
no matter where they draw the policy
line for what kind of content is allowed
as content gets closer to that line
engagement with that content increases
interestingly enough as part of the post
he um yeah he says our research suggests
that no matter where we draw the lines
for what is allowed as a piece of
content gets close to that line people
will engage with it more on average even
when they tell us afterwards that they
don't like the content so what this
suggests is it's not just that you know
people like this sensationalized
clickbaity content more
and just want more of it in their feeds
instead the issue is that sometimes what
we engage with
is
not necessarily the same as what we
might reflectively value
and recommender systems today almost
focus exclusively on these kinds of
behavioral signals rather than some kind
of deeper more reflective notion of
value
so this is where we get into the work of
this paper
the goal of this work was to try to come
up with some kind of framework in which
we can start thinking about measuring
some sort of more reflective value to
use as an objective function for
recommendation
the
words here very carefully chosen both
measuring and value
measuring because
we want to draw from this great body of
work and measurement theory
so i've been saying value value is a
super vague concept what does that mean
um here in this talk i'm mostly just
going to be focused on a definition of
value that is kind of individual what
would the individual reflectively value
at the end i'll sort of talk about how
this connects to more broader societal
value but even just that alone what is
the individual value is very vague
luckily you know there is a big field
that has studied how we operationalize
these sorts of vague theoretical
constructs in the quantitative social
sciences for a long time and we can draw
on lessons learned from measurement
theory to understand how we should
measure something like value on
recommender systems
so um in the measurement theory
way of thinking we start with some kind
of theoretical construct we have an idea
of what value is in our heads
but then we need to operationalize value
as something that is quantified that is
a variable
and unfortunately you know this variable
is latent i can't
look at you and a piece of content and
just see it you had 1.52 value with this
content
um instead we have to
um we have to learn what value is
through observed behaviors and that
in the recommender system setting this
is mostly the behaviors that you have on
the platform you know things like
favorites retweets replies click they
provide some evidence of value but they
are not value in and of themselves
so
if
um if we have these observed behaviors
we should be able to infer something
about value but of course value is again
distinct from the behaviors itself so
the way that we
relate the observed behaviors to value
is through what's known as a measurement
model which is a statistical model that
defines how we sort of observed evidence
relates to this latent variable value so
from this measurement model which of
course i'll talk about how we get in a
second we would get out the joint
distribution of these variables the
probability of value and all the
observed behaviors how do we then use
that in recommendation
well we do
very similarly to what we did before
we now replace the objective with this
probability of value given the observed
behaviors and we hope that of course we
can capture something that's somewhat
distinct
so once we have our measurement of value
we can use established approaches to
assessing the construct validity of
measurement to see how our
operationalization of value differs from
the construct itself that we mean to
capture
interestingly enough while there is this
gap between the measurement of value and
the construct there's also this gap
between the observed behaviors and the
operationalization of value and most
recommender systems only look at this
part of it how well are we optimizing
for behavior so we hope that by
expanding this picture even if we aren't
able to capture this theoretical concept
completely just this framework of
thinking can help us get closer to it
so what exactly is the measurement model
of course how do we relate this observed
evidence uh to value so this is the meat
of our contribution is in this paper is
a method
that is designed specifically for
recommender systems
so again we have um our behaviors we
have our latent variable value all the
observed behaviors are of course binary
you either favor something or you don't
we're also going to conceptualize a
value here as being binary you value
this piece of content or you do not
we will represent the conditional
independences between these variables as
a bayes net um so for example and don't
worry if you don't have background base
nets
the main thing is that it defines
certain structural relationships between
these value variables so for example
here i would say that favorite and click
are conditionally independent given
value
you might question that kind of
assumption though because users usually
have to click on something before they
favorite it so you might use a different
kind of base net so mainly the base net
encodes
these
assumptions on how the user interacts
with these different variables
but the base net just tells us about
sort of the structure
here and it doesn't actually give us
this joint distribution so how do how do
we learn what this joint distribution
should be
luckily for us on most of these
platforms you even if we don't know the
relationship between value and all of
the behaviors there usually is some
behavior which you're pretty certain
about so most of these platforms have
very explicit kinds of behavior like
reporting content clicking see less
often upvoting or down voting and we can
actually formalize the relationship
between value and these behaviors as an
assumption
so for example if you click see less
often on a tweet
you're pretty confident you don't value
the tweet so we can formalize that
assumption and write that the
probability the user values that tweet
given they've clicked c less often is
zero
we call this kind of variable an anchor
variable it's kind of explicit feedback
for which we know that when we see this
kind of feedback either the user values
the piece of content or they don't value
it
and it turns out just having this one
anchor variable is going to be
sufficient to learn what the full joint
distribution should be
in order to be consistent with the
assumption on the anchor variable
so the main
sort of result in our paper is a theorem
that i'm just going to skip going over
but
essentially what it says is that
through a few distributions that we can
very easily get including with this
anchor assumption
those will uniquely identify the joint
distribution of the latent variable
model
so to put it more intuitively the
designer has sort of two main levers
to pull when developing this measurement
of value they can choose what the anchor
variable is
which is basically the normative choice
um this is saying this behavior is
related to value in this way and that's
what's going to anchor how we interpret
all the other behaviors and they also
choose the base net and that's more just
like a structural substantive assumption
on how the user interacts with this
platform together these two design
choices are going to give us a
measurement of value that we can
interrogate
so we applied this to recommendations at
twitter for twitter's
ml based push notifications so just to
get on the same page about how ml based
push notifications work on twitter
these notifications you might get to
your home screen from which you can open
and see a tweet or you could be in
twitter see a notification in your
notifications tab click on it
and then after opening or clicking the
tweet you can obviously engage with it
in many ways you can also from
notifications tab click see less often
we're going to be using this as our
anchor variable
and at any point you can opt out of
notifications altogether
so using the method we developed
using c less often as our anchor and a
bayes net we wrote down we're able to
get out a measurement of value
of course the question is you know
what is this measurement of value
how do we assess whether it captures
what we want and so again to do that we
can rely on established methods for
assessing construct validity so for
example in the latest sort of gold
standard for measurement there are five
types of evidence for validity
here in in this work we're just going to
focus on internal structure evidence
based on internal structure refers to
checking that the internal variables
that make up your measurement follow
theoretical relationships you expect to
hold
so to sort of get an idea of that i'm
going to show a table of the probability
of value given each behavior and we have
certain things we expect like we expect
the probability of value given click to
say be lower than the probability of
value given favorite we sort of makes we
expect the probability of value given
opt out to be very low um but the other
behavior is to sort of increase the val
probability of value beyond the baseline
um so i'm going to show this to you for
two base nuts so you can see how the
base net affects the inferences we get
i'm going to skip the naive bayes model
which we just use as a very simple
baseline to show people doesn't work at
all um we never actually considered that
just showing it in the paper the first
model we wrote down basically just
encodes all the hard prerequisites that
exist on the platform so for example you
have to be in notifications tab before
you click on a notification
you can also just open the notification
directly from your home screen
after opening and clicking the
notification you can engage with the
tweet in many different ways
you can also opt out of notifications at
any time point
from notifications tab you can click on
see less often
and then value we assume can affect all
these behaviors
except notifications tab which is just
like a random event being a
notifications tab
um so what do we get out of this first
model
so
um
basically it's it doesn't really work so
the baseline the prior probability of
value is 0.5 um and so you know we do
get that like favorite and retweet
provide the greatest evidence of value
which makes sense but a lot of behaviors
are providing negative evidence of value
that are kind of surprising like open
click etc
and so we went back to see was there
something that we sort of missed here
and the thing we realized when we looked
at the data is although this model
captures all the hard prerequisites
um what we're missing is that most
people before they click see less often
on a tweet you know
click or open the tweet so they can see
what it is and so even though this isn't
a hard prerequisite um it it basically
is something that users do so we drew in
two additional arrows from click and
open to see less often to get our full
model which actually makes just like a a
lot of sense on first glance you know
favorite retweet provide the highest
evidence of value opt out probability of
value given opt-out is basically zero
you know click is less than like reply
that kind of thing
but it also makes
very interesting more fine-grained
inferences than that
um i don't really have time to go into
these so i'm not going to talk about it
but it's very cool to see sort of
fine-grained inferences that you don't
have to build in coming out of this
model
um so we talked about internal structure
that was just one small part of what we
want to
say you know you should do when trying
to evaluate this kind of measurement
i'm not going to go over all of these
but just
talking about you know relations with
other variables you would hope that your
measurement of value
i'm on the wrong picture but whatever
your measurement of value also um you
know correlates with user surveys of
satisfaction but is different than like
say clicks and then consequences
um you would hope that when you actually
deploy this model of value which so far
i've talked about is very individual
also doesn't have like broad scale bad
societal effects um yeah and so
to just summarize i've like talked to
you about a way of thinking about
developing objectives that allows us to
interrogate um the difference between
the operationalization and what we value
and i will end there thank you
okay thank you so much smitha um okay
i'm going to ask sarah and peter and
to come back up here and then we can
start um taking audience questions so if
you just raise your hand
get a nod from me which means i've noted
you and um
taken your name down and then we can
start running um
running through questions so
okay i'm gonna
come back here to bernard first and then
um once i give him the mic just hold
your hands up and i'll get everybody on
the queue
um yeah thank you all for
just really interesting papers um
i just have just a very immediate
question for smither which um
it was just i just wanted to know how
that um
your measurements sort of fed back to
this idea of a policy line and you know
if that's something that you can
is that something that is sort of
easily quantifiable in the sense because
that curve is really interesting and it
kind of
just in a very sort of slightly stupid
way it kind of reminds me of like that
classic
idea um that's found in like simple and
in psychoanalysis like you know the the
the but the boundary or the ban is the
thing that um elicits desire
um
and yeah so i just wonder if like if
there's any way to sort of translate
into that kind of more
um
abstract sort of way of thinking about
that you know and
yeah how those kinds of
that policy line adds up
um i wish i could think through
questions to the other people because
there was fascinating papers but yeah
and we actually have a lot of questions
so i'm just going to double them up so
hold hold burn
hold that question and i'm going to take
connell as well
thank you uh fantastic papers um i have
a lot to ask of everyone but i won't
given the
limits um and i'll say some things peter
that i hope in my talk later today that
we can talk about later
my question is for sarah
and it's on the i mean i'm generally
nervous about the creation of new rights
like bespoke riots um
as specifically as a response to new
technologies rather than handling them
through
more holistic um paradigms so that's my
baseline i'm nervous but uh my my
question is
um
would the exercise of the right that
you're talking about depend on a prior
right to contestation so
what is the trigger mechanism that lets
you exercise this right because it seems
like the attention at the moment is on
this right to contest
um so how does your right relate to that
and then related to that it seemed like
you worked through very different
contexts for in your talk i counted
about sort of three or four really
distinct really different working
practical contexts
and it struck me that the kind of harm
that comes up
in those contexts could be quite
different and you could realize the harm
at different very different points
within
you know that let's call it a workflow
so how does that relate like when and
how can you exercise a right like that
under those harm conditions
all right you guys can take your
questions
oh sure
um yeah thanks bernard at that question
um
so yeah i guess the question is um
to my understanding how does what i've
talked about could that actually kind of
counter effect uh
counteract the graph that i showed um
where you know sensationalized content
always gets more engagement or wherever
you draw the policy line it gets more
engagement so i would say this is kind
of like a long-term like five-year goal
of mine um
but it's actually there are a lot of
complications to being able to measure
whether an objective actually has this
kind of effect of like decreasing
sensationalized content
um or not so we are doing some other
experiments just measuring effects of
twitter's ranking algorithm
and we do see some perverse effects that
i can like talk about offline
and separately are also doing some
experiments to see how like the choice
of objective function in different
contexts um affects the kind of content
that you get but it's hard to link
everything together
because like to deploy an objective in a
real world setting you need to be on a
platform but then those platforms
themselves do not have the measures
ready to measure those kinds of things
like there's
like no measure of like you know how
angry our tweets that we are
recommending or something um so yeah it
just takes a long time to link up all
the parts
um
so thank you for the question that's
actually perfect and i
really appreciate this kind of pushback
because i think we're still actually
workshopping that um
because we appreciate the fact that you
know just creating a new right or
claiming a new right
is something relatively consequential
and shouldn't be taken lightly
and so we're
actually working through whether or not
we can ground it in existing concepts
and that might make it
not only stronger but also justify it
better um so we've we've kind of
looked at
um
both dignity and equality um
and read across a few um actual new
proposed rights like the right to
reasonable inferences um and so i i
think i'd love to have a longer
discussion with you about that
afterwards too um to get your thoughts
um the second question you had was about
contestation um that would indeed be a
huge part of it and i think there's both
kind of xandex x-post
actions that you can take here um
but it is largely you know there's um
margo kaminsky and i think
jennifer urban's right to condestai
and i think it would be
um really largely building off of that
um
there was a second part to your question
that i don't remember when different
arms arise like when you when can you
exercise the right in relation to the
harm
right so the first consideration is that
risk of harm um and
that is going to kind of affect when you
can exercise that right and that's
kind of the measurement stick where you
are not only evaluating harm but you're
also looking at who are the other
stakeholders in the system what are the
other costs that you impose on the
decision maker or on other individuals
so you can think of judicial economy as
a scenario where
actually they don't necessarily want to
have a ton of individualization if it
takes a imposes a lot of cost on the
judicial system and so you might
actually trade off for these things um i
don't know if that's answering your
question but
uh thank you
yeah thank you
can
i
you
hear
me
okay so um cornucopia of ideas and i
wanted to sort of engage everyone
hopefully on many points that won't sort
of take up the whole time so for smith i
was really interested that at the end
the value that had the 1.0 was the quote
retweet
and that just seems like what we hear
especially if you're trying to develop a
following in academia you want to
respond to really polarizing material
and i'm just wondering if that just
seems to be feeding in more i mean it
seemed intuitive but at the other hand
it seemed like i might respond to
something i really don't value and to
tell everybody this is really what i
hate anyway so i wanted to follow up on
that and then
also to engage sarah and peter serve
along the same dimensions
your talks are interestingly over um
overlapped so peter when we have this
idea of the collaboration where the
brains are um melding and it's
non-strategic
what kind of a response to this digital
era is this do we all need to become
buddhists and we bring that like all of
us that are engaging this world become
buddhists or do we need to not do the
digital world so just
tell us what to do
and then for sarah
i i was in your talk it i well first of
all can you say why it's so um you
personified the platform so many times
and talked about it as an eye
and i'd really like you to like why is
this platform and i
and why do i need to engage it in that
way and the model of trust that you use
is all rational choice in terms of
rational actor and this model of trust
is not the collaborative one that would
be in the peter's version of we
collaborate intentionally and we meld
our brain waves it's all where our
princesses are aligned and it's all
automated and it's all rational actor
thank you
great okay hold those helens is going to
ask her a question as well
yeah it's amazing because i had some
very similar reactions to yours and also
like a question about um
for each
uh
first of all sarah um forgive me i'm
going to be that person who says
i have a few articles that i've written
on trust online
and um
in one of them
[Music]
in one of them i kind of um
integrate a lot of the philosophical
work including
russell harden's but looking at in the
digital domain and
why it poses such difficulty for the
concept of trust
precisely
because
there is a difference between
trusting humans and then trusting
systems and sometimes
philosophers will suggest that we
actually use a different term that we
but anyway i i would like to suggest
those to you i can send them
um
but then
um
[Music]
back to that question of rationality you
mentioned harden harden
mentions the site this idea of you trust
um
we very for and others we very forgiving
if someone harms us
unless we see it as coming from an
intention
and that intention suggests future
future behaviors but if it's accidental
we
humans are very forgiving
so there is some rationality
that i don't think you can get away from
and you know it might be a good idea to
kind of just think about
how that fits
um for peter maybe a similar question
too is that i loved some of the insights
and kept saying to myself you know do i
need to become a buddhist
or is there a way to reason to some of
those insights
from a different kind of platform and
then
smither
i'm going to use the word overfit in a
way that i'm not sure that's actually
precisely correct but to what extent are
your
operationalized
is the opera
operationalization of value that you've
given which is
very smart but to what extent can it be
extended anywhere beyond
twitter are you hopeful
like are you hopeful to extend it but it
seems very
kind of integrated to the various
capacities that twitter has
no i don't think everybody needs to be
buddhist
number one but i think that it's
important that in engaging
new technologies when we begin
participating in these relational media
that we have to be coming in with eyes
wide open and we don't enter intimate
relationships with others without eyes
wide open
yet we somehow assume that we can enter
a very intimate relationship with
technology to the extent that we become
participatory within it
but it starts to inform the very shaping
of the own infrastructure of our
presence personally
we sort of take that as being a neutral
choice and i think we really should
problematize that that there's no
neutrality at all in engaging with
technologies technologies are always
value laden they're in fact
materializing human values
so we can't get around that so i think a
first step is yes coming in with eyes
wide open and what does that mean well i
think yes meditative practices are good
because one of the things that you do is
focus on patterns of attention see how
your pattern arises and how it shifts
and how it forms and where thoughts come
from sooner or later you realize through
meditating you're not in charge of your
own thoughts
and you're not in charge of your
emotions and these things are happening
and then you go a little bit deeper and
you start to realize however there is a
way of not exerting control over them
but it being present in a way
that the compulsive nature of choosing
the compulsive nature of being present
can be slowly dissolved so i think that
there's this can be framed in terms of
moving away from a logic where freedom
of choice
is the determining factor of how we
engage with these technologies you're
free to engage you're free to not to
engage
and i think that sort of philosophically
that's why that tool and technology
distinction is so important
because we cannot use tools i didn't
have a smartphone until about four years
ago when my wife and son insisted i'm
traveling too much they can't get a hold
of me and so on so i i use it as a dumb
phone
so i don't use it as a smartphone
but i can't get around the way in which
technology communication technologies
have changed communication practices
within families among friends and so
when i traveled in asia and was telling
people i don't have a smartphone and i i
can't
connect with you via wechat they think
that i'm telling them that because i
don't want to have anything to do with
them they took it as a personal affront
and so as they're like okay i have to
participate in this there's no way out
of it if i'm going to be a member of
society so your option is to withdraw
completely
or to engage in a way where at least
you're responsible for
your engagement
so i think what can help us do that
i think anything that gives us a longer
perspective on things than immediate
sense gratification immediate emotional
gratification
anything that helps us as human beings
to look further over that horizon
and to say where do we want to be what
are the relational dynamics that we want
to engage in but i think that's a really
important part of this process and
that's really about education
so if it was me i'd say preschoolers
i'll get training in basic attention
training
you know and from that point for at
least be able to be critical about
what's happening to their own minds as
they're engaging the world around them
okay um thank you for the questions so
i'm going to start off with the
personification one um didn't notice i
was doing it
but i do think there's a justification
for why i was doing it which is that it
comes from kind of the language that we
speak if i were presenting here and i
was speaking on how to design
recommender systems because we often say
you know we want to do this we want to
do that it might have even shown up in
the third talk um
in that maybe the algorithms themselves
aren't people but the choices behind
them are very much
ones that designers make and so we say
you know we're going to decide to
maybe model this individual as having
fixed preferences and we're going to use
clicks as proxies for their interest or
maybe not clicks
we're going to use whether they retweet
as a proxy for interest
so i think didn't notice i was doing it
i'm glad you pointed it out
really interesting question
second thing i think both you and helen
asked about was rationality um and i
might be misunderstanding where you're
coming from from rationality but i don't
actually agree
i don't think
the model that we adopt requires
rationality in the sense that the kind
of way the rationality as a concept
arose in economics was you have this
kind of base metric of what's beneficial
to you and that's going to be measured
in money and you occasionally will act
irrationally
where this very clear
unit of utility
you aren't kind of honoring that
[Music]
but the way that we look at it
is actually going to
capture and honor different ways that
individuals interact with a recommender
system so i could be an individual who
doesn't care at all i don't strategize
at all because i'm like you know what my
data's out there it's out there um i'm
going to let uh the platform do whatever
they want with it that's also going to
be captured or i could be someone who
really really cares
and tries to mask everything about me
that's also going to be captured or i
could be an individual who has different
short-term and long-term preferences
that's also going to be captured or i
could have be an individual who has two
different moods sometimes i want to be
shopping for professional clothing
sometimes they want to be shopping for
casual clothing that is also going to be
captured so i'm not sure if that's what
you're referring to but um
um
that
that or formalization is flexible enough
to account for those behaviors
um
and
helen might have had another question
but i don't remember and just want to
thank you for pointing out that there
are other works and this is an ongoing
work so i'm glad that
you're bringing us your attention
[Music]
yeah for sonia's question about the
quote retweet yeah i actually get this
question a lot because obviously quotes
on like twitter timeline are super nasty
so people are like why is the
probability of value giving quote really
high so you have to remember that we did
this um on specifically twitter's ml
base push notifications so it wasn't the
recommendations for like tweets you see
in your timeline and these push
notifications are already filtered to
basically be like notifications from
your friend um so they're already mainly
notifications that you like
um they're not from like i don't know
some other the others um
um so i think you see less of that nasty
behavior but that does go to show that
these behaviors are super contextual
depend on like the recommendations
people are getting um that's a just a
problem in general with these offline
recommendations so another thing that
like is useful about this method
practically is that for any you can just
re-estimate this at any point like it
takes like five minutes to run once you
have the data a little less than that
like 30 seconds and then you have this
new measurement of value so as people
change how they behave on the platform
obviously how that relates to value
changes and so the engineers on this
team are actually very excited about
this from a practical perspective
because
how they do it by default is like we
just test these weights in a b tests and
have no idea how to pick them
so having some sort of principled way to
re-estimate this was a big draw for them
and then secondly to helen's question
about how much does this generalize
beyond twitter um i think like for a lot
of platforms it can be sort of plugged
in easily when you have like these
binary behaviors a lot of platforms
don't do their recommendation based on
just like binary behaviors it's more
like watch time that sort of thing so
this model doesn't
easily like exactly what i wrote doesn't
easily extend to continuous features we
have been exploring doing like
approximations
um with different kinds of like latent
variable inference that can let you
extend it but also the
more broadly the general framework that
i want to push for of like thinking
about these things from a measurement
style like definitely applies um and i
think kind of opens up the box on like
what we think uh these objectives are
few minutes and a bunch of questions so
i'm gonna
gather all the questions and then maybe
each of you can like
okay thanks i'll try and keep it as
simple as possible but i love this panel
so much and i think it's really
connected to some of the things we've
been talking about already and the theme
and i want to congratulate the
curatorial team for putting it together
so as quick as i can so
for instance for uh peter um i i really
loved your presentation i think you know
we've been talking a little bit so far
about second order cybernetics as well
and it made me think very much of the
work of like francisco varela um
and and so i suppose
my question is
uh could you perhaps offer something
uh or your thoughts around some of these
sort of related concepts of
consciousness self identity that come
from varela and even to an extent like
gunter toybna in the context of legal
identity where they include um this sort
of relation these relational um and and
non-individualistic
foundations for the formation of
subjectivity but they don't necessarily
have to be between humans they can be
between other forms of agents as well
um i also you know
did this i have a quick question for for
sarah but it very much relates to to
to smithers paper as well um
and and also these questions that have
happened before i mean in in the game
theory approach to modeling human
interaction with the recommender system
what are the strategic imperatives of
each party and um
you know because when we think about
game theory approaches where you know
and strategic behavior like people yeah
they might not report their true
valuation of something in order to try
maybe get a better price for it or
something like that but what are we
thinking that the human wants to get out
of their interaction with the
recommended system and what does the
recommender system want to get out of um
their interaction with the human and
and to an extent it goes to this work
that smith is doing it's like how do we
define like inevitably we have to
flatten value to
to measure it
but um to you know to what extent like
is value necessarily inscribed by the
system or the designers of the system
through the mechanisms that we have to
to to measure it and um and and part of
that question then is also like if if
you're using a game theory approach
that's not premised on human rationality
however you want to define it like it
might there are other definitions of
rationality that are potentially more
complex but what are the categories you
use to model human behavior and
cognition
i'll try to be as brief as possible
so
to the first speaker
i think
it's a very interesting uh proposal
right to be an exception um one thing to
sort of uh just to mention as a person
involved in legal research this is a
deep deep question right what determines
if a case is an exception to a rule
right in fact you know there's a saying
that uh you know exceptions prove the
rule and so on right and one of the
things that sort of struck out to me as
being
a bit of a big issue is that sort of
rights
are just
the other side of obligations right if i
have a right to something someone has an
obligation to do something for me and i
can choose to to not exercise it right
in these contexts um one of the things
you mentioned is the determination of
uniqueness right or individualization
whatever right
somebody
has to determine that right that itself
is going to have
rules
um so
uh and what happens a lot of times is
especially from people who are in
statistics and cs they propose these
uh ways to improve these
terribly unjust systems and uh what this
does is essentially just creates this
tick the box situations where they say
okay i took this into account i added
this variable
now this this is just right so
and from from a legal perspective right
this this creates a lot of difficulties
for us in the in the legal domain
because we don't know math the reason we
go to law school is because we don't
know math right so
anyway it's it's a it's a i think that
should be something that should be
emphasized like you know hey um
this is this is not a way to sort of
justify these unjust systems right uh
and yeah just just what determines
uniqueness is itself a
fundamentally difficult question like if
i'm on if if a parole decision is being
made on me right
why am i not unique and another person
is unique that's some bureaucrat sitting
there and making this determination
right so it's a it's a anyway that's
just some general comments
thank you um
i had a question for peter that was
around uh why you chose the term hacking
um uh you know i would understand sort
of a lot of what you're talking about
through say the philosophy of karen
karen barad who we spoke about yesterday
um and so when you know if you're not
outside the phenomena with which you're
measuring when performing an experiment
for example and so the term hacking i
feel like implies like an outside
external actor who then you know
does something to like a system that
they're not involved with
so just a clarification on why the term
hacking specifically and then for
smither
uh
amazing paper um and i just had a
question around when you do your a b
testing are you testing on sort of a
specific group like is this even
generalizable across twitter such that
like some communities use and interact
differently to others for example
academic communities who are using it
for a specific purpose for promotion and
i don't want to look like a [ __ ] in
front of like my colleagues or whatever
but some people don't mind being like
that on twitter right so um
uh
so yeah i mean how do different types of
uh is that something you account for
when you're designing this sort of value
that certain communities use things in
certain ways and have engagement and
give signals that uh
some kind of way which is totally
different to her now the community might
do that
[Music]
okay we're gonna get one more question
we're pretty low on time so
you know lightning round responses and
then hopefully we can carry forward um
during the break the conversations
thanks i love this panel this is great i
had questions for peter i was really
interested in the definitions of tools
and technologies and i just wanted to
hear a little bit more about that
because
i got the impression that they referred
to different phenomena or things and yet
it's got to be relational right like one
person's tool is another person's
technology like a recommender system it
sounds like was a technology here but
for someone working at facebook it's
tool if that makes sense so just like
clarification on that i was curious
about and then i just i'd love i'll
probably just talk about this later but
i'd love to push you on what attention
means and on specifically what's new
about the new attention economy
okay
try to go between the three so varela
hacking and knew about the attention
economy
uh varelas was for those of you who
don't know he was uh originally trained
as a biologist i believe
and uh was interested in how cells
communicate
how communication occurs within an
organism and he was really interesting
in the sense that he wanted to
to move away from this
sender receiver model of communication
and to say that what you have is not two
separate sender and a receiver what
you've got is a relational pattern
that's playing out over time and you
can't understand organisms and
perception and cognition without
understanding that organisms arise in
connection with their environment so
there's kind of an early version of an
activist theories of cognition or mine
that's going on that has some
connections with people like andy clark
and his theorizing extended mind
i think what buddhism brings into this
is a much longer historical perspective
where
the arising of something like
subjectivity is connected with an
emergence of a new kind of consciousness
so in yogachara buddhism you have eight
consciousness it's not humans don't have
one we've got a
so visual consciousness is the
elaboration of visual relations in order
auditory consciousness is the
elaboration of auditory relations in
order etc for
smell taste touch
cognition is something that's different
in that it is elaborating relations
among the sensory streams that are going
on in the other five sense
consciousnesses so it's sort of object
creating
so connecting what's going on visually
auditory by smell and then creating
objects that hold all of those
properties together
for none of those for those sixth sense
consciousness is subjectivity required
there's not necessarily anything it's
like to be seeing
there's not necessarily anything it's
like to be thinking
thinking and seeing and so on can go on
without subjective awareness
so subjectivity arises by the seventh
consciousness and an eighth
consciousness we can talk more about
that
what's interesting about the arising of
subjectivity it's connected with the
evolution of new infrastructures for
consciousness language and culture
so buddhists talk quite a lot about
language and the way in which language
structures consciousness
and the problems with that
in the same way that with cultures a
culture is a way of getting things done
for shared consciousness and it's an
infrastructure for realizing shared
intentionality that's a good thing
but like any other infrastructure once
it's been in place for a while it starts
to determine what kinds of shared
consciousness you can have so it sets
norms for what's allowable
differentiation
so the idea of coherent differentiation
what kind of runs through the whole
understanding of consciousness from the
buddhist standpoint
so coherence and differentiation are two
core values
for understanding what's going on
and when we're engaging systems like
intelligent technology or cultural
systems that have to do say with gender
and so on what we're looking at is to
try to figure out how do you maintain
the conditions for coherence that is
things holding together over time but
also conserving the possibility for
creative differentiation so that becomes
crucial
uh i think that maybe answered a bit of
tal's question as well hope hopefully
sorry hopefully we're we're over
lots of good conversation to have over
coffee
thanks again
[Applause]
we
everyone
at 11 11
so you may want to